love it or hate it the first season of
the world's most expensive television
show has come to an end and you're
either like this
or like this destroy it
come with me on an adventure as we take
a look at season one's biggest questions
its connection to the books and what we
can expect for season two I've left
timestamps below for what we'll be
covering be warned this video does
contain season 1 and book spoilers one
of the biggest mysteries this season was
the identity of the stranger the
mysterious being that fell from the sky
at the end of episode 1 when the mystics
a group of wraith-like beings with
magical powers eventually catch up to
whom they declare that he is the dark
lord Sauron only to discover they're
terribly wrong so if the stranger isn't
Sauron who is he we know that he's in a
story a quinya word for wise one or
wizard there were five such Wizards
which included Gandalf Salomon and
radagast now the question then becomes
which one is he in particular is he
Gandalf and the evidence supporting this
is pretty heavy aside from the obvious
like him wearing gray and the ability to
control Magic The Stranger also says
aligned directly from Gandalf in the
film Fellowship of the Ring
and always follow your nose when in
doubt
Eleanor Brandy foot always follow your
nose furthermore when he dispatches the
mystics we see a symbol of a moth which
Gandalf used throughout the events of
Lord of the Rings not only that we see
him use the bright white light similar
to that used by Gandalf in Return of the
King Gandalf after all was known to be
associated with this white light what
puts a damper in this theory is that
Gandalf was not known to set foot in
Middle Earth during the second age even
though he would have been alive at this
time however I think there are some easy
ways the writers could get around this
should the stranger actually be Gandalf
from a completely TV executive point of
view you'd want the stranger to be
Gandalf as he'd be a big draw to the
show if I were a betting man at this
point in time I'd say the stranger is
more likely Gandalf than not but what's
next for him at the end of the season he
takes off with Nori brandyfoot toward
roon a land so far east not much is
known about it perhaps there he'll team
up with other Wizards and learn his true
purpose roon is also known to be home to
four Dwarven Clans so I wonder if Nori
and the stranger will link up with them
and perhaps even Prince Duren who I
imagine may be looking for somewhere new
to stay after essentially being
ostracized by his father the season
finale also gave us the reveal of Sauron
with red herring such as Adar and the
stranger prompting many viewers to
question sauron's true identity those of
you with a Keen Eye likely had your
money on Hal brand remember that Sauron
during this time put on a fair Visage
AKA he looked like you and I not that
armor clad Behemoth we see at the
beginning of Peter Jackson's Fellowship
he'll become that later on albrand
appeared seemingly out of nowhere where
Galadriel stumbles upon him while
marooned at Sea he like Sauron is a
master Craftsman and Smith remember that
it was Sauron who forged the one ring in
secret in episode 6 we learned that Adar
supposedly killed Sauron for
experimenting on his orc children so
when halbron asked him if he remembers
who he is he's wanting to know if dark
and sense that he's his former Master
another clue appears in the final
episode where halbrand helps Keller
brimbor solve his smithing problem
calling this knowledge a gift during
this time Sauron called himself anatar
the Lord of gifts and while he was never
welcomed in Linden Keller brimbor was
more than willing to keep him in a
region to learn from his art and
craftsmanship remember that Keller
brimbor wanted nothing more than to be
remembered as a great Craftsman hoping
to one day be as good as his grandfather
feenor who created the silmarils and
palantiri after the fall of sauron's
Master morgoth Sauron did repent and
turn away from his evil Deeds fearing
the Wrath of the Valar those spirits who
shaped the world he was ordered to
return to valinor to face judgment but
instead hid himself in Middle Earth so
when Sauron tells Galadriel he means to
heal Middle Earth he's not kidding even
Adar said that Sauron devoted himself to
the healing of it this is to repent for
all the evil he did while under or more
goth's control that is if you are to
believe him Galadriel did the right
thing here denying his proposal to
become queen of this new land but the
difference here is that Galadriel wants
to save Middle Earth Sauron Wants to
Rule it so he essentially lets her go
now I guess he could have killed her
here but he didn't maybe it was too
risky to kill an elf in the middle of a
region or maybe he knew he could keep
his identity Hidden Still after all
elrond also learns that Hal brand isn't
the real ruler of the Southlands when he
uncovers that scroll galatriel was
looking at in the river but when he's
about to confront Galadriel I got the
feeling he's not gonna do anything about
it earlier in the finale he said it was
a mistake when he sent her off in
episode 1 and that he should have
trusted her now he doesn't want to make
that mistake again and chooses to trust
her he doesn't need to know the truth
about halbrand just to trust and believe
that Galadriel is doing the right thing
at the end of the episode we'll see
halbrand make his way to Mordor it is
here that he'll Forge the one ring to
rule them all but that may take some
mithral in which case you'll need to get
to Kaza Doom where we saw a balrog at
the end of episode 7. Sauron will also
need to contend with Adar the man who
supposedly killed him so my guess is
that season 2 will see Sauron fighting
for control of Mordor the Orcs And maybe
even the creation of the one ring for a
show called The Rings of power there
were surprisingly not a lot of rings in
total the rings of Power are comprised
of 20. the three we saw for the elves
seven for the dwarves nine for Mortal
men and the one ring to rule them all in
the book the first to be created were
the ones given to the dwarves and Men it
was only after Sauron left a region that
kellebrimbor went on to forge the three
rings we see in the show so I wonder how
the writers will address this next
season it's not until 10 years later
that Sauron will create the One Ring
however considering the show has played
fast and loose with the timeline we'll
likely see this happening well before
them as the Rings are forward you can
even see the molten lava form the eye of
Sauron showing the Ring's connection to
the dark lord according to the book it
is Galadriel kirtan and gilgalad who are
the original bearers of these Elven
rings with gilgalad later giving his
ring to elrond each ring represents an
element Fire Water and Air which are
represented by these colored gems not in
the book is galadriel's dagger which
once belonged to her brother it'll be
melted down to fuse with the mithril in
making the Rings the Rings then become a
physical manifestation of both Sauron
and Galadriel sauron's Power and
galadriel's Light the expeditionary
force that set out from numenor has
arrived home to a sad sight black flags
Adorn the harbor which means the king is
dead before his death Chancellor R
farazon commissioned draftsman and some
apprentices including Ellendale's
daughter aaryan to draw the king but
during her meeting with him he grabs her
arm thinking she's his daughter stating
that if the old ways of their people are
not stored their Island will fall he's
referring to how the numenoreans once
were friends with the elves which they
now look on with disgust Aryan also
discovers the king's palantir an object
whose chronic use made the king unable
to separate what is and was and will be
Galadriel and Muriel were the only two
who knew of this object's existence
until now so I thought it was rather
interesting the writers decided to get
Aryan in on it too we never see whether
or not she touched it but if she did who
knows what she saw in the book farazan
usurp's power from Muriel and now with
her being blind this may even solidify
his claim she'll come back spouting how
they need to Ally themselves with the
elves and that people aren't going to
like that and thus back farazon I'm also
curious if the queen will use the
palantir as a way of seeing since she
doesn't have Vision anymore Muriel knows
what's at stake here she's seen in her
dreams a huge wave destroyed the entire
Island this does happen in the book but
Ellendale foresaw This Disaster perhaps
the result of the palantir and set sail
for Middle Earth where he and his people
will later found the kingdoms of arnor
and Gondor this season also left with
some loose ends for example where's
isildor last we saw him he was trying to
save the queen after the eruption of
Mount Doom and illendio believes his son
to be dead with him likely still in
Mordor I wouldn't be surprised if he
gets mixed up with the Sauron Adar
storyline we also don't know what
happened to isador's brother anarian who
was mentioned several times in the
season last seen somewhere in Middle
Earth now I know this was a quick video
thank you all for watching and please
make sure to like And subscribe I want
to know what you thought about the
season and theories for season 2 below
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember today is